your first 100 pound is more significant
than your first million and people are
like wait what and I was like the type
of person that you have to become in
order to make your first bit of cash
through business from then on it really
is a case of like scaling and repeating
and like putting systems in place but I
had a huge amount of growth from first
say a thousand pound that I made to like
the first million that I made it was
like I had become the type of person who
creates value so then it was a case of
you like figuring out what system am I
going to use to like scale my values so
that's why I often say that people go
well it's so easy for you to say but
like it is actually a true statement you
have to become a different person in
order to be able to give value to the
world and get paid for